[Applaudissements]
tu as franchement il règle les comptes
regardez nous bon sang de bonsoir délit
vous avez encore volé ma place de
parking mais si celle où on voit le
mieux ma bm vous n'avez aucun droit
parce que vous savez très bien que c'est
la mienne ok mais tu as fini de me
casser les glaoui chieti d'abord t2 au
kruger de la compagne je ne vais pas me
laisser faire vous allez voir ce que
vous allez voir l'afrique comme tu l'a
cassée il est parti pleurer dans les
jupes de sa mère bien sûr tu peux pas
test fédérer il est midi comme modèle
aux [ __ ] et il a repris sa place
raconte sa race jürgen regard et là bas
au fond avec tabbee x de merde à la
chaume à des rites dans une citroën sur
ma vie oui allô allô service parking
quelqu'un a pris la place d'un
inspecteur des vies qu ils sont
tributaires place à quelqu'un d'autre
la cause de leur mère dit largement cédé
remarie mes droits à l'eau c'est gbagbo
dans ce choix
qu'appelle-t-on connaît de beaux frères
le responsable du parking mais il te
déteste à ta femme non plus elle
m'aimait pas au début ça m'empêche pas
de là des boîtes et tous les mardis jo
c'est cette place là je veux récupérer
c'est là qu'on verrait le mieux ma bm
proches mois et se marrent ball et vient
garer sa mère qu de merde c'est quoi ces
dacca
il a quand même les phares xénon bois du
maroc et tu passes à la boutique quand
tu veux c'est pour moi parce qu'avec
c'est vrai que tu fais de la pub merci
des rides c'est gentil de ta gueule ou
d'eric un mot rendez moi ma place de
parking à placer à nos six à dire et
bien envoyé en titane est pris aux
mauvais tunisien qui a compris vos
méthodes sont déplorables d'eric vous
venez de vous salir les mains
les mains gelées mais un peu aux cheveux
et c'est souvent dans des gueules comme
la tienne
écoute moi bien tu vas te barrer fixe à
nos bureaux
sinon je vais prendre elton john lackey
avec toi et je vais te carrés dans le
cul là que candle in the wind
vous êtes ma part d'eric attias pas peur
non je n'ai pas peur monsieur n'a pas
peur mais regarde moi je fais dans mon
bureau et je chie sur ton bac en poche
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]